In this video, we are
going to calculate
interesting quantities
that have to do
with the short-term behavior
of Markov chains as opposed
to those dealing with long-term
steady-state behaviors.
But first, let us introduce
the notion of absorbing state.
As indicated in this definition,
an absorbing state is
a recurrent state from which
you cannot escape once you get
to it.
The transition probabilities
from k to k is 1.
So in some sense, you get
absorbed by the state.
For example, consider this
transition probability graph.
States 4 and 5 are
both absorbing states.
Indeed, when you get
to 4, you stay in 4.
Or when you get to
5, you stay in 5.
State 1, 2, and 3
are transient states.
So if the Markov chain
initially started in 4, then
it will stay in 4 forever.
If it started in 5, it's
going to stay in 5 forever.
But what if the Markov chain
started in either 1, 2, or 3?
Eventually, after
some moving around,
you will either make that
transition to state 4
and get absorbed
by it, or you're
going to do that
transition and get to 5
and get absorbed by the state 5.
So the question is, are
you going to end up in 4,
or are you going to end up in 5?
Well, we don't know for sure.
These correspond
to random events.
But can we say anything
about their probabilities?
Well, let us try to calculate
the probability that you end up
in 4 as an example.
First, it seems plausible that
this probability of ending in 4
will depend on
where you started.
If you start in 2, you
probably have more chances
of getting to 4 than
if you started from 3.
Because if you start
from 2, at the next step
you have immediately the
chance of getting to 4.
But if you start from
3, there is some chance
that you will go to
5 and never go to 4,
or you will have to go through
2 in order to get to 4 anyway.
So it looks like the
probability of reaching 4,
given you started
from 2, will be bigger
than if you started from 3.
Now, from 1, it's unclear.
Let us be systematic then.
Let us consider all possible
probabilities to end up
in 4 depending on
the initial state.
So let us ask this
question, what
is the probability, a of i,
that the chain eventually
settles in 4 given
that it started in i?
So in other words, a
of i is the probability
that you end up in 4 given
that you started in i.
Now, the answer to that question
is very easy for some cases.
If you start in
4, the probability
that you end up in 4 is 1.
And if you start in
5, the probability
that you end up in 4 is 0.
There is no way that
you can go from 5 to 4.
What about the other cases?
Well, it's not so clear.
Let us consider, for example,
that you started from 2.
What could happen next?
Well, from state 2,
let's build a tree.
You can either, with a
probability 0.2, go to 4.
Or with a probability
0.8, you will go to 1.
Now, in the first
case, you're done.
You reach 4.
But in the second
case, you arrive in 1.
And what happens next?
You don't know.
But what you know is
that from that state,
either eventually you
go and get trapped in 5,
or you go and eventually
get trapped in 4.
What are the probabilities
of these events?
Well, we don't know.
But one of them has
been defined before.
This represents the
probability of ending up
in 4 given that you start in 1,
and that has been defined here.
This is nothing else than a1.
So the overall probability
of interest for us,
which is a of 2, using the
total probability theorem,
you can enumerate all options.
It's with probability
0.2 you will go to 4.
And then the
probability of going
to 4 given that you started
in 4 is a4 plus 0.8 times a1.
Now, a of 4 is, of course, 1,
as we have discussed before.
So we get the relation
between a2 and a of 1.
Now, of course, you can do the
same thing for the other state.
For example, if you started
from 1, what can happen next?
Well, you can go to 2
with a probability 0.6.
Once you're in 2,
you're asking yourself,
what is the probability
of reaching 4?
Well, by definition, it's a2.
Or from 1, you go to 3
with a probability 0.4.
And given that you
have done that,
what is the probability
that eventually you reach 4?
It's a3.
If initially you start with
a3, what can happen next?
Again, with probability 0.3,
you will end up in state 2.
And there, a of 2 is the
probability of interest.
Or with a probability
0.5, you go to state 1.
And in that case,
you get a of 1.
And finally, with a probability
0.2, you get trapped in 5.
All right?
You can write if you want, but
0.2, and you get trapped in 5.
But we know that a of 5 is 0,
so this term will disappear.
So in the end, you
get a system here.
After you replace
a4 by 1 and a5 by 0,
you get a system of three linear
equations with three unknown.
And it is easy to solve.
I will not do that.
You can do it yourself.
But here are the results.
You will get a of 1 equals
18/28, a of 2 will be 20/28,
and a of 3 will be 15/28.
Now I expressed them so that
we can compare them easily.
And as a sanity
check, you can verify
that indeed the
probability starting from 2
will be larger than the
probability starting from 3.
And it turns out
that a of 1 will
be in between the other two.
So these probabilities
are consistent
with our previous intuitions.
As an aside, note that you could
have written a system of five
linear equations with
five unknown, the five
unknown corresponding to
the five states possible.
In fact, we had our
five equations here.
Here was one, another one here,
and 1, 2, 3, so 3 plus 2, 5.
Of course, this one was easy.
It was a4 equals 1 and a5 equals
0 that you can replace then
there, and you get a limited
or restricted or smaller system
of three equations
with three unknown.
Now, what if you had been
interested instead in finding
the probability b of i
that the chain eventually
settles in 5 given
you started in i.
How to do that?
Well, you can repeat
exactly all this calculation
that we have done, but looking
at 5 as the state of interest.
But of course, you
don't have to do this.
For any state i, given
that you started in i,
you will eventually
with probability 1
end up in either 4 or 5.
So you have a of i plus b of
i equals 1 for all possible i.
So once you have calculated
a1, a2, a3, a4, and a5,
you get b1, b2, b3, b4, and
b5 by using this formula.
To sum up, in general,
the calculation
of the probabilities to
reach a given absorbing state
s starting from any state
i of a general Markov
chain with m states--
so let's assume
that you have m states-- will be
the unique solution of a system
of m equations with m unknowns,
with the additional conditions
that a of s equals
1 and a of s prime
equals 0 for the other
absorbing states.
Now, going back to
the following question
that we posed at the
end of the review
on steady-state behavior,
we had this diagram,
and we wanted to know which
recurrent class this chain
would end up if it started in
one of these transient states.
Well, we can now
answer this question.
For the purpose of
this calculation,
the trick is simply to think
of a recurrent class as one
big absorbing state and
go through the calculation
as we have done here.
So think about this class,
for example, as being one
big state, an absorbing state.
And now forget about the inside
and calculate the probability
that you end up in this class
as the probability of reaching
this absorbing state given that
you started in 1, 2, and 4,
and you do the same
kind of calculation.